these are not armed Medics but disguised
Israeli soldiers inside a Palestinian
Hospital hunting a patient to kill a
targeted assassination in a civilian
Medical Institution in the city of
Janine in the occupied West
Bank according to the hospital staff one
of the three men killed had been
receiving treatment for injuries he
suffered during an Israeli Army raid two
months
ago this is a crime that can be added to
a series of crimes violating hospitals
and storming medical institutions
assaulting Medical Teams and
assassinating three young men we want to
reiterate our appeal to the
international institutions that they
need to stand by us and take
responsibility against these crimes a
statement by the Janine brigades which
includes a number of Palestinian armed
resistance groups said two of the three
men were members of Islamic Jihad and
one a commander the third was a
commander in Hamas Hamas said it was a
fully fledged War crime and a
continuation of crimes against people
from Gaza to Janine an Israeli Army
statement said what it called a Hamas
terrorist cell hiding inside the
hospital had been
neutralized it said Hamas Commander
Muhammad jalam had been planning an
attack inspired by the October the 7th
Hamas attacks and had been transferring
weapons and ammunition to other Fighters
Israeli Army often surround and at times
have actually attacked the three
hospitals in Janine during their nightly
military raids on the city but this is
the first time since the beginning of
the war that they have actually entered
a civilian medical facility in what
seems to have been a targeted
assassination and one the Palestinian
authorities are calling yet another
contravention of international law
Charles staford Al jazer rala in the
occupied West
Bank make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz